Street Fighter 6 is on its way and we've
almost arrived at his June launch date
every Mainline Street Fighter game makes
waves and Capcom changes the formula
just enough to Merit that numeral add-on
so here is everything you need to know
about Street Fighter 6. to start if you
haven't played it there's actually a
demo available right now for Street
Fighter 6 focusing on the game's world
tour mode available on PS5 PS4 PC and
Xbox series X slash S so if you are
interested stop watching this video go
play that and come back
come on if you couldn't tell by the
grizzled look of Ryu Street Fighter 6 is
set in the future of the series after
the events of Street Fighter 3. as the
game takes place after the events of
Street Fighter 3 you can expect to see
both familiar faces who survive the
events of that game as well as plenty of
new faces so let's quickly go over the
roster before we press forwards
returning characters include Ryu Ken
Chun Li Blanca belsium E Honda Zangief
Kami guile DJ jury and Luke new
characters include Jamie JP Kimberly
Lily Manon and Marissa Street Fighter
games have slowly iterated on a system
of meters that can enhance attacks and
open up new windows of opportunities and
for Street Fighter 6 there will be an
all-new drive system to play with in
short this is a system of five special
moves and includes drive impact drive
Perry Drive Rush Drive reversal and in
overdrive art to master once mastered
the drive system allows you to absorb
attacks close gaps counter-attack when
trapped in a corner and repel any blows
thrown at you based on how much of your
meter you have available to work with
the drive gauge has six bars to work
with and you'll spend one bar per Drive
action running out of meter will place
you in a burnout mode and leave you
vulnerable to punishing a fence until
your energy is restored even if you
block you'll still take chip damage in
the states and you'll want to stay on
the defensive as this will help you
refill your drive gauge more quickly one
of the big changes in Street Fighter 6
is a more varied set of controls that
players can choose from if you're
confident and prefer an old school
approach then the classic control scheme
is for you and will allow you to pull
off advanced moves using traditional
inputs the modern control type allows
for easier inputs where a special move
can be performed by combining a special
move button with one directional input
essentially streamlining the entire
process for an even easier option the
dynamic control type is an AI assisted
feature that ensures that you'll always
use the best move possible depending on
your positioning in a level this will
allow you to unleash one button combos
Gap closing moves from mid-range and
automatic projectiles from long range
the catch here is that the dynamic
control mode is only available in local
play and functions as a way to allow
anyone to play Street Fighter 6
regardless of their skill level next up
there's the major edition of world tour
mode World Tour allows you to create
your own custom avatar as you travel the
world in your search for the answers to
the question of what is strength this is
an open world where your custom avatar
can explore Metro City and learn how to
become a world Warrior by interacting
with Ryu Chun Li and Blanca Beyond being
able to customize your Avatar's General
appearance you'll also be able to
purchase gear from an apparel shop that
will affect your abilities that said you
can also opt to just use it for visual
purposes for That Sweet Street Fighter
fashion this mode has RPG mechanics
where you'll gain experience and be able
to level up your basic stats Like Your
vitality punch strength or kick strength
you'll also receive skill points as you
level up that you can use to increase
the number of special moves and arts you
can use or unlock other skills by
training with the aforementioned
legendary Fighters you'll be able to
learn their various special moves and
mix and match them to create your own
unique fighting style with your favorite
set of Moves Like spinning bird kick or
Flash knuckle another addition to Street
Fighter 6 is that it features a
real-time in-game commentary from some
of the biggest names in the fighting
game Community Jeremy vicious Lopez and
tasty Steve are two shoutcasters who
recorded lines for Street Fighter 6 and
the dialogue is designed to provide easy
to understand explanations about
gameplay so that rookie Fighters can get
a better grasp on the systems of the
game this feature will support subtitles
in 13 languages for more accessibility
and Capcom says that more details will
be revealed in future updates
for multiplayer Capcom has added a few
interesting ideas for creating a global
fighting game Community fighting ground
contains traditional modes such as
arcade online local versus and training
Dojo meanwhile you'll also be able to
take the avatars you've created in world
tour mode and take them into the battle
Hub online to fight against other
players created avatars battle Hub
resembles a gigantic arcade and it's
where you'll interact with other players
if you're not challenging other people
in the room you can organize a
competition or sit down and watch a
tournament play out this space can fit
up to 100 people so there's a good
chance that someone online will be
looking for a friendly fight to ensure
better online play Capcom has rebuilt
its rollback netcode from scratch and as
seen in the recent beta it's a hugely
forward when compared to Street Fighter
5's heavily criticized adoption of that
technology rollback netcode is a system
which makes online fighting games feel
as if they're happening in the same room
due to there being barely any lag
between inputs when it comes to
tournament rules Capcom has made a major
change to the use of level list
controllers and its Pro tournaments as
the developer says that if a player
inputs up and down directions at the
same time then both inputs must either
be maintained or rejected in a nutshell
this has a significant impact on those
controversial controllers especially the
ones manufactured by hitbox which gives
players a sizable advantage in matches
and allows them perform certain moves
more quickly than competing players who
use standard fight sticks or controllers
as is now standard in fighting games
Street Fighter 6 already has planned DLC
with new characters coming out April
Street Fighter 6 showcase revealed the
first four characters that will be added
after the game's launches Street Fighter
5's Rasheed will arrive first bringing
his powerful moveset of win-based powers
with him and he'll be followed by a new
character in Fall 2023 next up Aki a
mysterious woman with a pale appearance
who uses Chinese martial arts and Claw
based Weaponry to slice opponents to
Ribbons then there's another returning
Street Fighter 5 character in Ed who
will be releasing winter 2024. lastly
fan favorite Akuma steps back into the
ring and not too much has changed here
building the dark powers of the satsui
nohado Akuma his hard and decisively and
it'll finish you off with his signature
raging demon attack if you give him an
opening so far Capcom is advertising a
year one pass that will unlock those
four DLC characters when they're added
to the game this season pass can be
purchased separately or alternatively
it'll be included in the deluxe and
ultimate edition of the game for the
in-game currency players will be able to
buy Drive tickets that can be used to
purchase Cosmetics as Street Fighter 6
will have various alternative costumes
to acquire and dress repair characters
up in Street Fighter 6 will release on
June 2nd 2023 on PS5 PS4 Xbox series X
slash S and PC the standard edition will
cost you 60 and is available to
pre-order at Major retailers Street
Fighter 6 also comes with a free upgrade
from PS4 to PS5 the deluxe edition will
cost you 85 bucks and comes with a bunch
of goodies most notably the year one
character pass with the pass you get
those four additional characters as they
release and new outfit colors for them
in addition to the year one pass you can
get 4 200 Drive tickets the in-game
currency next up the ultimate edition
which will cost you 105 notably the
ultimate edition is only available
digitally it comes with the year one
ultimate pass as well as two additional
costumes for all four characters you'll
also gain access to two bonus stages and
7 700 Drive tickets finally there's the
street fighter 6 collectors edition
which will cost 250 big ones it's a
GameStop exclusive and only available
for the Xbox and Playstation editions of
the game this one includes everything
from the ultimate edition as well as a
number of physical Collectibles a mad
gearbox pop-up parade figures of Luke
and Kimberly a sticker set artbook and
figure diorama boards and that's
everything you need to know about Street
Fighter 6 which character can you see
yourself choosing the main let us know
in the comments below and we'll see you
next time